what's up guys bang bang this week was a
wild one in bitcoin so of course we're
gonna break down key statistics on chain
metrics and we're gonna try to
understand what the hell is happening in
the bitcoin market and what's likely to
happen in the future let's get into
these bitcoin metrics brought to you by
ftx us
first we're gonna look at bitcoin's
price sitting right around twenty nine
thousand dollars spent a little
volatility but it's down about four
percent in the last 24 hours if we then
go ahead and take a look at bitcoin
statistics we can see that the market
cap is trading around 550 billion
dollars again still staying with that
inflation rate about 1.77
and over 90 of the 21 million bitcoin
have been actually issued into the
circulating supply we can see that the
real exchange volume here is just over
three billion dollars there's over a
million active addresses and miners have
been paid 26.5 million dollars over the
last 24 hours to continue securing the
most decentralized secure computing
network in the world
bitcoin is now down about 57 from its
all-time high but it's up 12 from that
recent cycle low if we then go ahead and
we take a look we can see that bitcoin
is down 25 over the last year gold is
also down as is the s p 500 but over any
other timeline two to ten years we can
see that bitcoin continues to
drastically outperform both gold and the
s p 500 and then if we kind of look even
closer the bitcoin price we can see at
this 29 000 level that their spend in
bitcoin's history only 496 days where
it's traded at a higher price that means
that about 89 of bitcoin's life was
lower if you bought during those days
and had until now you would be in profit
then if we go take a look at the
compound annual growth rate we can see
that bitcoin's compound annual growth
rate over the last 10 years sits at 137
absolutely destroying gold s p 500
nasdaq or tlt and then that five year
sharp ratio sitting at 1.24
still drastically better than any other
asset in these comparisons looking at
these key market statistics at bitcoin
are great but obviously bitcoin also
provides on-chain metrics there's nobody
better in the game than the folks over
at blockwear will clemente putting out
some great research this week if we go
ahead and we take a look at these charts
we can see here that bitcoin's price is
starting to approach that 200 weekly
moving average that blue line just
dropping closer and closer to that price
then if we take a look at this next one
the on-chain price levels we can see
that the short-term holder realized
price which is in light blue we're
underneath that meaning the short-term
holders are likely underwater but
bitcoin's price still moving closer and
closer to that aggregated realized price
which sits around 24 000 or so that
historically has served as a great point
whenever bitcoin's price gets near that
it usually can signal that we're close
to a bottom then of course the mv rv z
score you can see here on the far right
bitcoin's price dragging that further
and further down towards that green zone
then if we look at the futures perpetual
funding rate really there's not much to
see here it's just kind of sitting
neutral there's not a ton of volatility
to the upside or the downside which is
important to understand
one thing that the blockwear team has
identified which i think is super
interesting is this idea of a geographic
premium in this week's newsletter they
went ahead and they talked about how the
asian trading hours actually are putting
a massive premium on price we've seen
this before as they wrote asia's
dominated this market for the last two
years they sold the early 2021 top they
bought the summer bottom they sold the
first pump off the summer lows they
bought the dip to 40k and then they were
selling heavily in november and so asia
continues to be at the forefront of the
market and right now they're placing a
premium on the price in today's market
then let's go look at the bitcoin whale
holdings what we can see is that bitcoin
whale holdings obviously were
drastically impacted by the luna
foundation guard having 80 000 bitcoin
reserves but as they started to sell it
pulled that number down so what
blockwear did was they went in and they
pulled out the lfg 80 000 bitcoin
reserves number so this is looking at
whales not including that organization
and you can see that both the increase
and subsequent decline in whale holdings
those are much more muted now then let's
go take a look at the supply hold by
retail and as you can see in this green
line going up and to the right
all the way to the far side it's just
going vertical now we're seeing more and
more retail they not only are continuing
just to stack sats and kind of dollar
cost average in but they're obviously
taking big purchases at these price
levels and then lastly one of the most
important metrics in the entire market
is how much of bitcoin's supply has not
moved in at least a year and right now
we're sitting at an all-time high over
65 percent of all bitcoin in circulation
has not moved in the last 12 months and
of course it's not just about bitcoin
itself somewhere how gold has gold
mining stocks we should also take a look
at bitcoin and then the bitcoin miners
dylan leclair over at bitcoin magazine
he had a great point he said the
publicly traded bitcoin miners in btc
terms continue to crash over the last
six months these have gotten killed
because equity multiples have compressed
and hash rate has risen while bitcoin's
price has continued to fall now nobody
knows what's gonna happen in the future
but what we do know is that there's a
macro backdrop to bitcoin right now
there's tons and tons of speculation
about what the federal reserve's gonna
do and they seem to be in control as
they've continued to raise interest
rates as they said they would tons of
assets have all sold off stocks bonds
real estate much more bitcoin hasn't
been safe from that but of course the
big question in all of global finance
right now is will the federal reserve
continue to increase interest rates will
they pursue 50 basis point hikes or will
they at some point have to cool off
maybe pause all those interest rate
hikes that are planned or maybe they'll
actually even give us an interest rate
cut before the end of the year i don't
know what's going to happen but what i
do know is that just like in a liquidity
crisis where all asset prices start to
correlate towards one
that's the exact same thing that happens
when we enter into these quantitative
tightening periods and so naturally the
federal reserve's in control and it
seems like everything is just one big
trait bitcoin holding up very very well
though only down about 60 or so from its
all-time high it's doing much better
than many of the riskiest tech stocks
and so the million dollar question is
going to be what is the federal reserve
going to do
as always i hope that you guys enjoy
these and of course we'll be back next
week with many more breakdowns around
the bitcoin key statistics the on-chain
metrics and any other metrics or data
that we find interesting i want to thank
ftx for being the sponsor this week ftx
us not only can you go buy bitcoin other
cryptocurrencies but also they just
announced stock trading so go in the
description you can go ahead and click
on that link and get started with fdx us
until next week i hope to see you guys
on the internet hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time